[Musik]
sie sind schwestern und brüder sich dann
weiter in der öffentlichkeit
abra schmid-federer aus nationalrat in
der achterbahn feder aus abt vom
benediktinerkloster einsiedeln
aufwachsen sind aus katholiken
reformierte stadt zurück
was hat sie bewegt was verbindet sie
bestückt und wo könnte meine carmen und
barbara schmid-federer und urban feder
sind mit geist der staat und religion
herzlich willkommen
das hat damals erste katholische familie
familie und ich habe festgestellt dass
diskriminiert werden
mit meist untereinander sprachen die
eltern sich nicht mit ruhm sexy und der
innerschweiz einer demonstration mitte
konfession es hat hier sind damit der
körper spanier zum beispiel spielt die
religion unterrichten sie nur zwei
katholischen religionsunterricht anhang
egal und und hand daneben außerhalb von
suurhusen und riss das hat mich schon
sehr prägt aber jetzt muss ich ganz
ehrlich bin dankbar für die erfahrungen
des bildes mit dänischen minderheit ich
weiß wie sich bereits offen lege den
muslimen oder juden oder andersgläubige
innere große gruppen ihnen und zum hahn
ich wahrscheinlich aktion das bedürfnis
ist 13 jahre jünger sind im ried ich
habe die erfolge nicht so ganz nach
konfessionen religionen haben die jugend
große rolle spielt ist im kontext mit
schwankender so ausgeprägt hat
eigentlich österreich so dass
diskutieren das mit neurologisch dass
man sich weiterbildet bildet hat große
rolle gespielt und kultur gehört
vielleicht mit meiner die klassische
ausprägungen im kopf hat also sie es vor
allem im sport stars ist spitzensport
gange und ich so viel musik gemacht
stellt wiederholung angst ich würde eine
mögliche tour lernen in dieser familie
wenn es mal ganz untersagt werden
ururgroßvater josef seien immer
schweizer center burg oder erste
katholische bundeswehr spitzt sich also
eine politische persönlichkeit erste
bundesrat ohne demokratie könnten
katholisch-konservativen gespielte
bedecken die beute familie da gibt es
mir wirklich lustige episode
das hat mir gewiss dass mir unserer
familie zusammen und ich habe einen
ziemlich berg in zügen aus
genau so einen vortrag halten über t
und das tollste zell drews die kultur
des konservativ-liberalen ich habe kein
ikea das ist eigentlich berg im herz der
kolonialismus kombiniert mit und ich
selber kann vor dem jahrestag aus ganz
unterschiedlichen vor sich gegangen ich
habe mich als kind immer mit politik
befasst und annika das nicht und
bundesrat haben bitte familie angefangen
mit der person betroffen bin ich bin
wirklich berühmt gemacht hat und was
ziemlich einfache symbole auf dem
friedhof der gruppen auf dem bundesplatz
und das gibt mir denn immer wenn ich
berufen würde jetzt als zeichen für die
verbundenheit
sie sind beim nationalrat gang oder die
hand sie auf das reagiert wo sie
kandidiert
also ich bin natürlich dem land stammten
aus den augen was immer möglichst weit
und hat mit vier briten zwar im kanton
zürich selber über allen für die
politikerin wie sie aber natürlich ist
das system eine familie
sie spannen sie natürlich auch um werde
man spart das bessere position auf
verwandtes öffentlichkeit und das muss
sich ihrer gewinne ich bin ein kanton
schwyz natürlich angesprochen worden
sagt dass die nicht wusste und was heißt
zuzuteilen
aber münchen 17 eine kleine weile wunder
wenn sie denkt eigentlich wollten was
ich eigentlich machen irgendwann ich
eigentlich zurück wenn es um
parteipolitik ereignis möchte - gab dass
ich mich mit ihrer sehr guten start und
eine gute erinnerung das ist das was uns
verbindet und man also nicht den
minister
denn oft seien sie reagiert oder wird
heute das kostet ja das ist eigentlich
mit ganz einfachen moment kratos
mitteilte blieben zum kloster versteht
zum zug und hat eine große zukunft im
ersten moment so rolle eigentlich ein
schock
das hat dann so nicht stattgefunden
und ich muss sagen ich fand es wie
gebucht bis es mich ob der gedanke von
anfang an fasziniert was sagt das ist
jetzt am brett aber möglich aber das hat
sich dann mitte jahren vollkommen
verändert nicht eine forderung deshalb
will ich einfach gesehen dass er sehr
glücklich ist in dem masse macht es
passt zu ihm
er ist die rolle gewachsen aber
eigentlich ist das tut mir natürlich
leid und hätte ich gern vor dem brief
bei abos im emsland und im nächsten
biegung und durch schulden ja also
eigentlich mit dem skifahren auf einzige
hoch das board und nach der diskussion
habe keine klaren ton ist nach der rs
ich muss diese frequenz lechstadt einher
so rezar gerätes zur studie aufzeigt ist
ein trojaner das institut für mich nicht
ich habe mir das in den letzten jahren
immer wieder leid aber nicht auf fragen
wirklich vorhaben befindet meiner
schwester ständig nehmen oder mit ihrer
auftritte selber russische gewisse
zurückhaltung eigenes gut
der handel von pharmexx und handelns
machen desto schwieriger als vorher
[Musik]
schön sind sie beide über das wunder ist
doch religion politik oder ihren cvp
präsidenten gehabt das spiel zwischen
islamisches land sind sie besonders mit
60 maschinen christlicher richtig
richtig installiert und nächstenliebe
dass das vom die altarbibel sehr stark
da musst du durch richtet sich vor allem
nach der arme nach und schlossen oder
apollo mission nach flüchtling und wenn
ich mich richtig land ist nicht die
erste frau mit flüchtlingen mit armen
und doch das will ich bin aber ich meine
ein tor schießen aber das licht mehrheit
von der schweizer bevölkerung kommission
und restaurant gehört mir ist lieber
nach vorne stellen oder
zwei sachen gefragt hier ist es richtig
los und ich es richtig schwer kritisiert
dennoch flog das ist die arena xia oder
und präzisiert wörtlich so verdanken
dass wurzeln in sachen sind juni
schließlich müssen wir für mich aus dem
trio eine politik macht und sie noch
nicht sagen ich kann für mich mit
harpune der bezug zu jesus christus
also es was ich um das richtig gestalten
muss ich immer irgendwo masse was unsere
region durch die person jesus christus
vor dem herr ich mich auch wichtig dass
ich das richtig oder was würden sie dazu
sage dass ich natürlich nicht programm
quasi das programm sondern titel ist
bereits angesprochen wurde
tradition vom fleck das ist eine
unschöne ganz andere diskussion die
frage noch wert ich bin eine kontrolle
haben sie gefühlt jetzt oder begriff
regisseurin halters er wurde dass die
wenigsten dass darunter verstehen aber
ist jeder song der mit seiner frage
reden ihr eigenes verwehrt und mit augen
von ordnern wertvorstellung sind so
ziehen vollständige und normen sind eher
so dass oder drei tage ist die messe
vertreten da muss man sich eine gute
frage nächste lied ist verknallt wurde
was sind es überhaupt so behält man
herzlichkeit verschiedene musikstücke
aber gut war jedoch dank ihrer füße was
enorme was muss erst die verkaufspolitik
sie natürlich sagen ist in den
demokratischen rechtsstaat und auf dem
wasser ist sauber und mitte kein
religiöser gottesstaat
also da muss man schon bescheid ich
mache mir wirklich erhöht was man aber
hand in hand sehr wohl einfluss durch
die christliche traditionen an die
christlichen festtage beginnen
aber da muss man auch sagen es gibt auch
es gibt dadurch einen brief
so zum beispiel wenn sie zahlen
geschrieben edition arabisch oder wenn
sie das unternehmen die teile von
kalendern ist das jüdische staat collage
dem sinn was hat den vorrang
von der spitze und religion selbst noch
mal ein blick zum beispiel ein
integrationsvertrag vorschlagen
da steht als zweiter punkt das recht
steht über der religion ist privatsache
sehen sie das auch so foto sagen dass es
so dass liebe vor allem wälder stark der
glaube an dich seite und iv die ämter
glaube es heißt nur die religion
das ist ein unterschied also es ist
richtig unter dem motto auge fassen
religion und spiritualität licht aus
begriff sporne spiritualität so wie
heute gegenüber ein geistliches thema
das sie sofort aus und jede dem
staubsauger für sich entscheidet was sie
was er da will religion an sich viele
aus dem begriff von einer organisation
ich finde ich mir privat viel politik
das wort heißt eigentlich schon für die
auto- einheit für öffentliche und
religion erzählen muss ich mit der
öffentlichkeit zu gewandelt da wird sie
wieder sprache religion ist privatsache
oder glaube ist das beweist er glaube
aber das recht steht über der religion
zum spielort den einsiedler abt vom
großverein siedlungsstraße gibt über
über einsiedler unserer gemeinschaft der
ganzen schweiz war die international
viel geschwitzt privatsache ja das ist
unser training ohne die sind mir nur die
fahrt auf
dass der name für sie nicht bestimmt was
er was sie glaubt dass es mit gesamtes
arbeit aus dem café platte müsste ich ja
hochstraße ich möchte ja in excel
schafft in die stimme heben oder ein
kelch durchmacht
das ist übrigens auch ein wenig glauben
regionen sind
jahrhundert auf den öffentlichen raum
und für mich überhaupt nicht geholt wenn
china
sozusagen als subkultur im untergrund
nur befragt irgendwo bewegt oder sich
entwickler ziemlich wichtig dass ich
irgendwo im öffentlichen raum ist und
vor besonders beim burka-verbot zum
beispiel sind sie begeistert ich hatte
mich in die diskussionen will eigentlich
der islam ausschließen will ihn
eigentlich ein zurückdrängen und und
duden als äußerst zeichen setzen dass
burghausen irgendwas anderes im umgang
zwischen regierung und fordert aber es
ist doch so ein punkt wo wir sagen das
symbol für die sich norm für eine
religion wo zum beispiel zeigt einer
messe vor dem forum für einen
fortschrittlichen islam freiheit ist
gott gar nicht um das foul von drei
geringer sondern ums frauenbild dass ein
solches stoff gefängnis für frauen
vermittelt ich bin in hamburg hoffen die
befürworter aber ich will ich wieder an
das team aus lingen
foto im randvoll ihre waffen lagert und
bbva toni kroos und selbstverständlich
möchte ich auch mit ihnen in dialog eine
breite dass sie dass die frau achtet
dass sie genau nicht zudem zu den
schnelleren verdammen aber das kann ich
nicht machen indem es ist das nächste
für statistik der zusage der berg ist
nötig
sie haben vorher termine funktion als ob
tierheim gerät gesellschaft von der
schweiz ausgestrahlt und ist meistens
gab es heftige diskussionen
das einzige dadurch muss ein ort ist wo
eine interkonfessionelle aber auch die
routine straub oder das große wissen tue
also weit vor anderen konfession und
sogar religion unterrichtet oder das hat
ganz stark mit der madonna mit das
wasserniveau in lang nehmen nur für
katholiken kaputt zuerst wird das ist
noch interessant
ich sage das nicht verkehrt so will nur
über konfessionen konnte und jetzt laden
oder der islam verehrt ja jesus aus
profit- und seiner mutter maria und
großer stimme merken koran und hinüber
und vor dem hera geht's immer wieder mit
dem islam nicht total eines bildes sehen
würde unternehmen dazu äußert und zurück
aber einen dialog unter den edition
networks noch nämlich eine aufgabe es
wäre was nicht kontraproduktiv an hier
das künstliche würde der züge mit
aber meine hände stets vor mit 105
schülerinnen und schüler gibt es bei
musliminnen muslimen die hand aus
die meisten sind richtig es geht aber
auch um islam und sowieso und die sind
dann befreit vom religionsunterricht von
konfessionellen feier vertretung
reformiert aber sie müsse transit ich
bringe für mit dass sie die schule
befindet und dass hier bis vor seine
position zu lernen
und das ist für einen kreis zu beheben
aber das ganze privat ist oder es ist
üblich auto einen öffentlichen auftrag
hätte sonst überhaupt wird der dialog
unter den religionen dass ich es kurz
stichwort dass ich nach längeren und cvp
kommt und für user immer wieder
förderten religionen und mir wirklich
hat die einzelnen regierungsvertreter
mit den anderen sind und mit denen
diskutiert und genau das ist für mich
der richtige weg dass man die diskussion
lanciert und daran ist natürlich eine
andere zuordnung zum islam oder zu bei
juden aus richtig gesehen dann halt
bietet sogenannte normale islam oder
judentum sehr gut läuft und dann auch
ganz besonders bitter ist ein beschluss
zu den extremistischen islamisten oder
wurden die neiße liegen die dinge anders
als politisches religiöses sehr gut
gemacht und das muss ich sagen für
jugendtrainer und wo nötig machten
und da mal ein anderer zugang ich kann
ganz gut ich würde empfehlen sich mit
religion auseinandersetzen
ich glaube der waldfrieden prämien in
österreich sind immer wieder thema
die hand aus dem geiste mit der sonne
über religion reden zu langen herkunft
warum eigentlich einfach sehr sehr klare
3 nicht vor fielen im juli in der
wittenberger noch weise werde die teak
und durch daraus dass sie bis genügend
über religion reden und das thema dass
religion und gesellschaft in der
botschaft kann dazwischen und nahm sie
würde dort nehmen sie viele dinge im
moment wenn sie gerne zu jeder krise
gibt es ja durchaus sinnvoll ist das ist
amtlich ihr umfeld für die eigene sohn
ferdinand und täter gibt ein enges
zusammenspiel vor allem jetzt wo fließen
alle gelernt sich jetzt interessant ist
das beispiel frankreich
ich bin schon längere zeit in frankreich
geklappt und ich konnte genau die
erfahrung gemacht
also genau das was ich eigentlich los
und landet wege steht da passiert was
die hand anderen religionen integriert
sich nicht um die krim
das hat subkulturen die hand noch
irgendwo entwickelt man erfolg hat und
am schluss an die gesellschaftliche und
religiöse spannungen so steht's mit dass
mittlerweile die religions- und
kulturelle gemeinschaft hat und das mit
nötig wir haben diese schnitzer sind
sehr erfolgreich unterwegs mit ihm
dekoration und nicht mit assimilation
mit integration und sind eigentlich
diese persönlichen erfolg
die gutmenschen forschung bewerben
die feinde kaiserstraße und religion
aber religion ist für die meisten
menschen mit mit systemen müsste doch
das konfessionen erreichte ihn
regungslos ist also folge zurück sido
mitglied im sport sind wichtige
praktiziert offensichtlich viele bekannt
aber es hat nur zehn von ihnen
tatsächlich praktiziert also insofern
kann man sagen dass mit gezwungen
die katholische viele leute total
minderheit ist und das andere schon sehr
viel
und trotzdem fängt sie dokumentiert wie
genau die religiöse frage der
öffentlichkeit diskutiert sich das über
genug beisammen haben sie ganz großes
brandes großen preis und bild von mir
der richter sieht diskussion beteiligen
wenn sie die verhandlung werde
schumacher aussetzen einer belohnung
ich danke mir qualitäten inklusion im
herbst vorgelegt das größte in zukunft
unserer größe werden spiele bestimmt
glüht hand zum teil große mühe mit
religionen für sie soviel von kraut
gehört konfessionen verschwindet oder
unbekannt sich nehmen zu aber ich merke
dass in trance limit zum beispiel am
inneren tradition haben dass auch die
tradition aus dem benediktinerorden ist
konkret zu überqueren ich will sehr
angesprochen und worte eines dreiecks
leitbild 1500 jahre tätig wenn ich sehe
wo zum teil arbeitet conti mit
wirtschaft ihnen ein großes internet wo
im alltag von sich sagen nein mit
religion und nützte das heißt aber nicht
dass es diesen winter des systems und da
ist es ja auch ziemlich schön dass man
nicht nur über so einen dialog führte so
einem resultat mitunter genannt hast
musst du es ist mit löw versicherte
sigrid religiös und zwar aber wie
freundin sondern spiritualität was ich
sage dass wir im dress von für zukunft
haben
ich danke dir für mich muss der nahmen
sie mittelpunkt steht immer wieder hoch
erhaltet fünfmal am tag in hand aber
nicht nur die strukturen
damit stehen stiftungsgesetzes
gesellschaft von mir und sehr vielen
medien sirup pflicht aus irgendwo sie
dritter hand wo versucht wieder in der
rechten szene true entstehen
das sind zum teil basic vergisst denen
das ist der große religions- disco für
die medizin aber hält das zölibat gut
sich gemeinschaft vermögens gemeinschaft
besonders betrifft wir den rhythmen oder
verreisen aber in die
römisch-katholische dvp liberale stoffe
die u bahnen verzählt von der familie
von der frau ihre berechtigung haben
schimpft sie wollte mit ihnen mit ihm
direkt nicht die tatsächliche zeit auf
mich ein wenig wirklich ganz bewusst
gewählt hat und von dem her wenn er das
so will und ich gesehen dass er dabei
durch geschichten dann sind die
katholischen viele wirklich bestätigen
was im notfall vertrauen das eigentliche
endlich wieder nichts stört mich das
wirklich fundamentalen es gibt keinen
objektiven grund und ich finde die
schweiz fordert dass man sich wirklich
leid dass der strom werde aber bis sie
sagen das praktizieren oder symbole wie
sie sagt sätze wie das ist natürlich
klinik meinung viele gemeinden und jetzt
zum beispiel bei mir wohnen mit ihm
kommunizieren liberale weltoffene
gemeint kleins vorstellen dass er lieber
draußen
das ist ein mittel oder das oft ideen
für eine kleine serie
bereits mit der öffentlichkeit
ja denn sehr konservativ vornimmt oder
wo sie dass du mit sache konfrontiert
wird wohl zum beispiel kommt alles ganz
anders räte und dann wird dafür
konfrontiert mit dem was im hotel die
salamander entsprechende bundesrats in
unserer zeit
das gehört einfach dazu wenn wir der
öffentlichkeit ich muss sehr oft zur
beständigen und der gegner kommt anders
der nägel plan aber ich es nicht aber
für unschuldig und einzieht sehen die
hause hauptvereins das spiel zur
bischofskonferenz ist chance bekommt mit
wie könnte sie jetzt mal ernsthaft über
sonnige fragmente räte und wenn damals
zweifel selbst war trainer in die
römisch-katholische sonnige vor gerettet
was mir aus übrig das ist ja nicht so
dass wir nur immer solche spitzen
offensichtlich ein kontakt mit der
schule aber bitte ich ja gerade so
wissen sie wann simon abend über mit
medienfonds oder um zusammen und waren
überaus diskussion für internet so
beträgt die land existenziell komplett
problem der kz-überlebende konform mit
bekannten frauenfrage wieder die
stellung der frau in die
gesellschaftlichen entwicklungen ganzer
länder ein bild von der frau zum
beispiel aber das ist dann der fokus in
der walküre heute so wie sie experten
handeln und es ist ein mann konnten
andere sicht wenn sie jetzt von regem
eintritt in der siedlung gelebt und sie
aus teilen von bischofskonferenz von
einer welle 2 milliarden automatisch
anders reagieren und agieren als novizin
kann passieren dass ich dieses dass ich
später wohnen
oder das ist das natürlich inzwischen
recht gut zusammen läuft angst
hervorrufen und man sie dann dort aus
auf grund nehmen und dann diskussionen
die katholische viel mitgeben
wenn ich das machen ja aber das sind
schon noch süße regionalisierung aus
übermut franziskus der schriftform die
karte gibt seite versuchen durch nie
regional das heißt der einzelnen
bischofskonferenzen verantwortungsgefühl
sind es häufig bund und sind in
prozenten zum gruß roth sieht die
soziale medien mit welcher botschaft
ich schließe auch im nächsten mit der
kommune steht die botschaften für
christliche werte und mit 1 205 zum
schluss noch unklar
mit dem tennis star roger federers in
der wand oder nicht manche schweizer ist
das ganze muss sagen dass mir meine
vorfahren
[Musik]
ok also nicht direkt verwandt sondern
vor dem großen apple stores hilft
beherrschen sind großartig und wir
wieder unten korrigiert
mit der familie feiern mit der familie
geschlossen ganze ist ja da gehts weiter
mit dem film über der anba damian
ein charismatischer bischof der koptisch
orthodoxer viele in deutschland ist ihm
zu wenig zeit der box franziskus genau
denen koptisch-orthodoxen christen euro
gestärkt
[Musik]